the sexual instinct is one instinct but
there are
many other instincts as well there's the
instinct of self-preservation and there
are social instincts and aggressive
instincts
there's a whole host of different
instincts and the animal represents the
totality of the instinctual world
an animal never consists only of sexual
desires
a dog for instance those dopamines they
have
aggression they have the need for food
they have the need for affection they
have the need for
being with other dogs and so on and on
and so ins if
a woman singles out the sexual instinct
as the only instinct and runs it with
her head
then it is counter instinctual because
it's out of balance
it's choosing one instinct against all
the others which nature never does
nature keeps a kind of homeostasis or
general equilibrium between the
instincts
and turns one instinct on and then the
other half and on and off again
if you if we observe animal life they
they
it's periodical there are periods of
sexual for the sexual instinct there are
situations for the aggressive instinct
their situations of
the collective herd instinct and so on
those rhythms are regulated by totality
by the wholeness of the being so only
man is
stupid enough that he can pick out one
instinct and
perform only that one instinctual
performance and then naturally that is
against the wholeness of
of the instinctual world and then he
does harm to his own body
and to his whole life